[Musique]
au début mars la vie de lorraine
mélodies et shannon a changé du tout au
tout elle faisait partie de la
distribution du spectacle bazar du
cirque du soleil et s'apprêtait à
débuter une tournée américaine
lorsqu'il survenue la pandémie non maman
je voyage prendre 35 à 45 vols
internationaux par année je fais 200
spectacles par année
je suis habituée de faire 8 à des shows
par semaine devant beaucoup de gens du
jour au lendemain elle passe de la vie
de tournée ou confinement dans les
premières semaines je commençais à avoir
des petits bobos partout juste des
arrêtés
one shot de bougies ça le corps réagit
d'une façon et pas que je connaissais
pas parce que ça faisait des années que
je bougeais à temps plein mais on se
réorganise les difficultés que connaît
le cirque du soleil et l'incertitude qui
entoure la reprise détournée des
spectacles vivants devant de grandes
foules des a forcé à repenser leur
avenir m'a vraiment aidé à passer à
travers puisse essayer de commencer des
projets personnels mon copain et puis
deux amis sur la même rue on a fait une
présentation spontanée sur la rue rivard
du plateau mont royal puis douleur comme
en partie l'idée de créer un collectif
le collectif l'apc acronyme pour
performances circassiennes urgence
présente cet été des spectacles
itinérants dans les rues enfin cartes et
c'était difficile parce qu'on s'est
vraiment fait demander de ne rien
inventé puis deux mais c'est pas tout le
monde qui veut non plus à l'est vers le
numérique
puis c'est vraiment super de plateformes
nous on voulait vraiment garder ses
seuls
le vivant l'humain à l'humain jamais le
souhaite elle aussi rendre cette pause
forcée productive et agréable j'étais
parti pendant tellement danic de d'être
au québec c'est inspirant sinon c'est
sûr qu'il ya des petits projets des
études en parallèle avec la carrière
d'artiste de cirque pour savoir lorraine
participe à montréal complètement cirque
il réalise des projets qu'ils n'auraient
pas pu accomplir avec la vie de tournée
j'essaie de voir ça dans une façon
positive que word peut-être je vais
grandir comme artiste dans une autre
façon en travaillant avec les compagnies
indépendant personne ne sait quand et
sous quelle forme le cirque du soleil
reprendra ses activités
mais elle espère être de nouveau de
l'avoir sur des petits 3 sont convaincus
que quoi qu'il arrive
montréal restera une ville
incontournable dans le domaine
circassiens piscine a dit alexandre
chartier adieu canada montréal